social care workers of today catering in
a crisis that's existed for decades
and as another winter wears on staff
here are feeling the pressure the NHS
cannot operate or survive if social care
is
run to the ground we have the hospital
ringing us all the time looking for beds
and spaces and there's not the funding
for the the staff don't get paid enough
now the country's most senior church
leaders weighing in with a new report
calling for Meaningful change and tax
Rises to fund a universal social care
system as you actually write in the
report for 25 years politicians have not
grasped the Natalie we even had a prime
minister in Boris Johnson he announced
plans for tax Rises were you dismayed
when that came to nothing certainly it's
disappointing
um though
one has to recognize that politicians
have enormously difficult questions of
priority but this is one of the most
fundamental questions affecting our
country morally and ethically but also
because it has ramifications and effects
all over the country an acceptance that
taxpayers across the country will need
to dig deep when it comes to funding it
is going to have to come from taxation
which means from all of us there is
going to have to be
responsibility for individuals it's no
use saying we can do it on the cheap
because we can't Archbishop what would
you say to people that might say to you
this isn't your job this is a political
leadership issue not a religious
leadership issue I would say caring for
people is very much my job it's very
much the the role of the church but a
big group in society not feeling cared
for after the church of England refused
to marry same-sex couples with only
voluntary blessings allowed this an
uneasy tension for the Archbishop if you
were not the fast among equals would you
personally bless same-sex marriages I
support the use of these resources so I
uh it's they they Bless the people in
saying so it's a Harold for you not to
be able to do what you personally would
like to do then no I accept that it's
part of my role it's just the way it is
but you accept that there's a conflict
there that's uncomfortable yeah it's not
comfortable but you know
the church is deeply divided over this
issue deep political divisions to over
how to solve an NHS crisis made worse by
a social care system struggling to
survive bath Rigby Sky News